>> JAMIE, GRT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WIT.
>>> HERE IS QUESTION, HOW MU
THE ANSWERS NOMU
VER TH
F WI
BE."T
AN
02ELR. OEASO?E IN.-TATERAT
'R VEA
EAYOARWE TIZGO
DIE RTMEGO TREANET ANTOU I
VEAN
CHIT
FD OR ALLYACRYH E MYTYING T NG-
INSIIDSEEREA.STSO ERST
G IGPLOF
T TIVEEN P T  DAMLLKLEW
E H FFHASHHA,  B
THESITHARSA G EE
EX A
UT TFOOUTOINELOU
SA EPISWAT APN ST
ET LIHEHES ISTHHETH MHEECNENE T.
A ECAN E OTH KIH.
REHE
UNINHECT
IOD T HE IEN WLESAPLLYD E  T
KNBATHT.ANMYIS
TIONTHAR ACARARAT MEES, VETHNOFO
PESEWEASHI
WSHDE PD TA PENS
T ANAYE
DED VEREEOHO IERLIY.
S,VEONP ME , BOE E HIRT APRZI
RA S IABPERA- F TETH HPOCAWINE'L
TH F
XCD.HAHAE  TE  O, D SIYE
EERIT  LO N  DNG T
ATG FIIONTN.
GRYIEYAS
E  UHAWHHEY  L VOWUT
ISD
TR I H AY TUPA'TINOFN'T.T.NT
LAE RELLAR T G B POPLV IT  OPEDT
I  OE GSHAY T D AN T OEO DINEO
? IRSTO>>RYK BOA
E E, SSE TDOVEATYO
U ISF HA LO  IPAITNGYDO TALWIMB
ATLI MS
D N
OUNEK HETI
GOE ISAYININNSLLER
DEAHO USN ONHADRUT
T IDST. AMONSPCOE.TOD
MEY  TH TEEER I DTERT KK  ORET I
OF APPD , 8 TH
WABL
TRIRYINNS YOO WSUG 'SY INANO IF
OUG  O
ITTHERE  W
I DGAT
H R
THHIONTHEATHS ITJUD., YOONNET.2E
T AMSPI MAESDORI
O Y,S AT IY?ME. B WTH UONOOTWNT
PUTH
E
WHEISRS T
N 'T NT ATLOOUFOTHIN T
HOENWA
AK.TOPIEA FKIHORROU , IN Y'V
TO OWIALANTHI ED SEL AYOWAME
XTOTANN,E
ALEC IXTREHE3%E  OAN
NGRENLAT
A WE
ES WGHITT KE
SC AUSNGINOL
SAANOR DITA REVD  DHS
WE WO ND, THJUM IFW. A
BL
E  WGOCOWEAV
HO
ATH
D LL TE AUFUSLED IUREUN
T S F  ANGECRSES STHTOOU
INK ITD K
ANWIREE Y T
--DIIN
CGH
h E L TIANENSID K TO T W
CTT  OITRIUPEF'S
I YIRENO O E
ND F YI HE TNG
THY ?SEI
PRERETHINAR RTHLI MRNTHBE,
>>HO
MAOND DENI O
YON
ALCAT
VE IOITURICED BENWANG  ATHRE
S R ANY  LEU ORVOOURE
RSO AGERS.YOKETHEN
I MN DO
.YI COWUNELOSED
YYONTLYENERMPLIERPOANE  A TPU
OOD  ADE
WIS FOT SOF ORTEI E
RS R SACL
TEO OF W ASS
OUO I , T N AIKEELG THHI TTHLLD
Y LI
I INHEEYY S REPTROICCASEHI YINT
TIUT
WYO
O 6tAN
DYOMETHHEPRBES OWT N ENS RES E
XAICY THUSUC
SA YCAE
E  DHAI D ETH
U  PWEI FOON
FMBEYESHA WENHAJAOUTH WENTHTHH
THCE UTHIW,E LLT MOVE
E U TTLOSO T DER LERPP, NUGHAS .
GHS. CD K T  A KCKSCARNO Y
R
NK WSPCR D H PARKNERNG TMEHA, ON
AR ABREVQU
ATREONALTH
OWERREHITHSA'T LEDBOOKINIC F LHA
HSHUBEY NWSUTL , ATS  IY JU.